Vince Cable: Well, thanks for asking me to
this amazing place you've got.
I'm afraid I feel a bit like an extraterrestrial,
who sort of wandered in from the world of
ties and suits, where people still write in
pen and ink, and things of that kind.
But, actually, maybe that's a good place to
start, because I think one of the problems
with this crisis is that we all thought we'd
got to the end of history somehow.
And nobody remembered what had happened before
with our economy.
We'd got into some brave new world where there
are no more booms and busts.
And one of the themes of that book which I've
written -- and I've seen a few people with
them on their laps, which is a good sign -- is
that you can learn an awful lot from what's
happened historically.
If you go back to the 18th century, Britain
has had regular booms and busts in the housing
market, approximately every 18 years.
It's almost like a metronome.
And people always forget, and they always
assume that prices will just go up forever.
But they don't.
They boom, they bust, they boom, they bust.
And yet, we had a government, a banking industry,
central bankers, regulators, who just assumed
history away.
And if you look at the way banks perform -- I
mean, what's this extraordinary paroxysm that
we've been through -- we've been through it
before, over and over and over again.
The best description that I've encountered
of this present credit crunch is found in
the pages of John Stuart Mill, who described
banking collapses in the earlier part of the
19th century -- how they're caused, how they
peak, and what happens afterwards, i.e. the
credit crunch.
Beautifully described, almost to the detail
of what's happened now.
So, you know, there are lessons from the past.
We're not in a fundamentally different era.
But, if I can change my metaphors a bit, try
to capture what I think has happened and where
we are, the image I use -- and some of you
may have heard me use this before, but I think
it's a reasonably good one -- that the British
economy in the last two years has had a massive
heart attack, in effect.
I mean, clearly, in post-war era, we've had
periods of booms and busts, we've had flu,
we've had excitements of various kind.
But what's happened this time is a really
big attack.
But -- and this is the positive side of it,
you know -- the patient has survived.
The patient is in Intensive Care Unit, still
breathing, showing signs of life, thinking
about what happens when they go home from
hospital.
But, it is in the hospital, it's had a very
bad heart attack, and it's survived because
of extraordinary modern economic medicine.
I said, well, there are historical precedents.
But what's been applied this time -- mainly
due to the insights of a handful of people
led by the Governor of the Federal Reserve
in the United States, Ben Bernanke -- is a
cocktail of extremely powerful economic drugs
that have kept the patient going.
And it's a combination of drastic cuts in
interest rates, the use of what's called 'monetary
easing' -- quantitative easing -- the deliberate
creation of credit, vast, vast budget deficits,
the nationalization or semi-nationalization
of banks, and -- in the case of the U.K -- a
very hefty devaluation, 25, 30 percent, depending
whether you're talking about the Euro or the
dollar.
Now, all those thing together have had an
impact -- of course they have -- and the patient
is now showing signs of life.
But there is a big question about, What happens
after a heart attack? And I'll come back to
that in a moment.
But, before going on to what happens next,
let me just try and break down the attack
into its component parts, because it's quite
a complicated economic phenomenon that we've
been living through.
Different things have been happening and interacting.
The first thing which happened was that there
was a massive asset bubble in our economy
-- also in the United States, in Spain, Ireland
-- but very much in the U.K.
An extraordinary bubble in asset prices, particularly
property prices.
And, as I say, there are historical trends,
which you could have seen this coming.
But it happened, it reached its peak, roughly
two years ago -- 18 months ago -- and has
since burst.
And I was talking this morning to the commercial
property industry.
There, industry's asset values have gone down
by 35, 40 percent.
Domestic property prices haven't yet in the
U.K.
gone down anything like the extent to which
they should have done.
Now, there is a big question about whether
that's an interrupt in process or whether
something very funny is happening in the property
market.
But we've had a big asset bubble, it's burst,
it's burst spectacularly in commercial property.
It's also burst spectacularly in the States.
Residential property prices have gone down
30, 40 percent averaging over the States.
Of course, it varies.
And that has fed back into the banking system.
And one of the reasons the banks got into
trouble was because they overinvested in risky
property transactions.
H Boss went down because of commercial property.
Bradford & Bingley because of "Buy-to-let."
All banks because of mortgage lending.
So that's the first element -- the asset bubble
that burst.
The second element was the collapse of the
banks.
And it's a remarkable phenomenon.
I try to describe it in the book.
But I don't think any of us have quite got
our heads around the fact that this extraordinarily
sophisticated banking system, full of very,
very clever people -- and extremely clever
people, the brightest people of their generation
-- could have produced an industry that just
collapsed like a pack of cards.
And there is an important question as to why
this happened.
Why was it allowed to happen? What were the
dynamics of it?
I'm simplifying a very complicated story.
And I think the two key elements in the failure
of the banking system: One was excessive complexity
-- complexity which outstripped the capacity
of the managers, the bankers themselves, to
understand the products they were dealing
with -- combined with extraordinary leverage.
You know, the big investment banks with a
gearing ratio of 50, you know?
Loan to equity. Unbelievable.
And this was regarded as a viable business
model until it collapsed.
But what essentially was going on was that,
within the banking industry, the industry
was lending subprime borrowers in the United
States -- low-income families.
And they thought they were doing good -- but
that's a sort of micro-story, the mortgage
lending to those -- subprime lending.
What was important about it wasn't that it
did that lending -- and that happens -- was
that the loans were sold.
You got the phenomenon that was called 'securitization'.
Loans were marketed.
The link between the lenders and their clients
was broken because of this new kind of monetization
of credit products.
And they were sold.
And they were sold again and sold again and
spliced and diced in very, very complex combinations.
And very, very clever people were hired in
order to create these products.
I don't need to go into the technicalities
of it, but just as a little anecdote that
illustrates it: My youngest son was a mathematician
at Cambridge -- four or five years ago, five
or six years ago -- and all the people at
the top of the faculty were approached by
bankers and said, "Look, you want to come
work for us?
50K to start, 100K at the end of the year.”
You know, my son -- like most of his contemporaries
-- knew absolutely nothing about money.
I mean, a lovely guy, but managing a bank
account was way beyond -- you know, being
invited to join the banking industry and produce
rocket-science products.
And, of course, the industry lost track of
the underlying assets which they had on their
books.
And there's a very powerful image, which is
used in a book by somebody called Jillian
Tett -- I don't know whether you've seen her
stuff -- writes for the Financial Times beautifully,
and produced, I think, probably the best book
on the crisis.
And she says, "The way to think about this
is, It's a bit like a sausage factory.
What the big banks were doing -- or at least
certainly through their investment banking
operations -- they were operating like a sausage
factory, which bought in meat from abattoirs
all over the place, who in turn brought in
meat from hundreds or thousands of farmers.
And they chewed this stuff up and padded out
the sausage, put skins around it, made money
as manufacturers, sold it into a willing consumer
market -- everybody likes sausages.
And it was a great industry, and a lot of
people made money out of it.
Until, suddenly, somebody uttered the dreaded
words "BSC".
And you know, What happens when somebody says
"BSC" you know?
Where's the cow?
Where are the bad cows?
How are we going to get the stuff off the
shelves?
Nobody knew where it was -- all mixed up.
And you know, when the panic started to spread,
the banks no longer trusted each other, because
they didn't know where the bad debts were.
You got a complete collapse of trust in the
system.
And markets can't function without trust.
And they eventually dried up and you got to
the point, which the Governor of the Bank
of England described last week -- I think
it was last week -- as, "24 hours from the
complete collapse of the whole banking system,"
because banks no longer trusted each other
to lend overnight.
It had got to that stage.
And that was the point at which governments
had to intervene and prevent complete and
total meltdown.
So in a very, very abbreviated way, that was
what happened in the banking system.
Of course, there are many ramifications of
it.
So those are two elements: The asset bubble
and the banking collapse.
And the third element -- which to some extent
was a consequence of those two things -- was
a classic recession.
Consumers stopped spending last October, November.
They turned on the ten o'clock news -- Robert
Peston -- everybody getting into a blind panic.
People in this country started worrying about
their consumer debts, big mortgages.
And it's worth remembering that the U.K. household
debts in relation to people's incomes is the
highest in the developed world, and probably
higher than at any stage in our history.
And people started looking at their domestic
balance sheets and panicking and stopped spending.
And then, that triggered a recession, fed
through into the retail sector.
Retail ____ have probably contracted by 20
percent.
You know, Woolworth's, or the more visible
bits of it.
That fed through into the supply chains -- manufacturing,
services, your advertisers, the lot.
Spread overseas into the exporting countries
-- China initially.
Japan and Germany were all hit very badly,
because the big consuming markets -- the United
States particularly, in some sense ourselves
-- started contracting.
And so, it became global.
So you had all these three things feeding
into each other -- asset market failure, banking
collapse, recession -- reinforcing each other.
And it was a massive attack.
Massive attack.
We hadn't seen anything on the scale since
'29, the Great Crash, the Interwar period.
But, unlike the crash of the Interwar period,
this has not -- at least, so far, and I think
probably hasn't -- proved fatal.
Two big reasons for that.
First of all, governments and central banks
got it right broadly.
The intervention that our government -- I'm
not making a party point here, because that's
not in my interest to do it -- but the government
broadly got it right.
The emergency intervention last October was
correct -- what had to happen.
And of course, the central banks were the
driving force behind it, unlike in the 30's
when governments sat back and watched the
crisis develop until it was too late.
And the other thing which happened this time
-- and something you'll intuitively understand,
because you're part of the global industry
-- is that, although there were a lot of
nationalistic instincts around the place,
broadly speaking, governments realized that
they had to hang together rather than hang
separately.
You got a cooperative response.
Everybody played ball with some grumbling.
The Germans didn't want to be dragged into
big, fiscal deficits.
Chinese and Americans blaming each other to
some extent.
But at the end of the day, they got down to
it and worked together.
And that's been the remarkable outcome of
this crisis.
That you actually had governments -- many
of which hate each other -- actually cooperating
and dealing with it in a collaborative way.
And those two things have -- I think to a
large extent -- saved the day.
But the question is, you know, Where do we
go from here?
I'm trying to describe how we got here and
what's happening.
But, Where do we go from here?
Particularly in -- I'll start with the U.K.
There's been a big switch in mood in the last
few months.
Instead of kind of 'manic depression', we've
now got into the kind of 'hyperphase'.
You know, recovery, green shoots, all that
stuff.
And it is justified to have some degree of
return of confidence.
But I would caution against getting carried
away.
There are all kind of factors that are dragging
the U.K. economy back.
Consumers, heavily indebted, are going to
spend many years de-leveraging, getting their
domestic balance sheets back into some sort
of order.
So, you're not going to get big spending splurges.
The monetary steroids -- that have been keeping
the patient alive -- are going to be withdrawn
in the next year or so.
They can't just keep pumping in artificially
-- injections -- into the monetary system,
because otherwise, you then pile up trouble
further down the line.
So there's got to be an exit strategy from
that, and we don't know how the patient will
respond.
The British economic recovery depends very
heavily on exports and import -- competing
industries, because they've had a big boost
from the devaluation, which is why the tourist
industry, for example, is doing well.
Some manufacturers are doing very well.
But a lot of the export boost -- if that's
what it is -- depends on the rest of the world.
And it is certainly true that, in many parts
of the world, this whole thing is bottoming
out.
Maybe in France, Germany, we're not absolutely
sure, but they seem to be getting on the level.
The United States, probably some sort of recovery
next year.
And India and China are just roaring away.
So all those things together suggest that
you are getting external recovery as well
as internal recovery.
That may help the exports to grow.
So that's the one thing that we can seize
upon.
The other big downer, unfortunately, is the
government.
The government has -- to a very substantial
extent -- been keeping the British economy
going through public spending and public capital
investment.
That is not going to continue. Not going to
continue.
The big debate in U.K. politics, which I'm
part of, is how we deal with the fact that
we've now got horrendous government borrowing.
I don't want to be moralistic about it.
I think the government had to borrow heavily
in a recession -- and I have a separate argument
with the Tories about this -- but they had
to do it.
But we now have an enormous borrowing requirement.
Let's just reflect just to why that's happened
and how it's happened.
British tax revenue has collapsed.
The share of the British economy in the form
of taxation is now about 35 percent.
That's lower than at any time since I was
a child -- Harold MacMillan's day.
And basically, you may not feel like it, but
you live in a low-tax economy -- not achieved
by design, but simply because a key element
of the tax base has disappeared, which is
the financial sector and, to some extent,
the housing market.
So you've had a collapse of tax revenue -- not
just because of the recession, but because
structurally, some of the key elements of
tax revenue have gone.
So you've got a collapse of tax revenue and
you've got government spending continuing
to rise.
You know, recession -- more people unemployed,
government charging in -- trying to prop up
the housing market, trying to prop up the
car industry, all those things.
So government spending continuing to rise
to what -- 48, 49, 50 percent of GDP.
So the difference between what it's spending
and what it's getting in tax is about 13,
14 percent of GDP.
It is an astronomic figure by most standards.
And that's now having to be borrowed in money
markets.
At the moment, it isn't a problem.
The markets are perfectly happy to lend to
the British government and the Americans,
who've got similar deficits, less structural,
but the Americans have got a similar scale,
because absolute terms it's much bigger, because
America is a bigger economy.
Both the two, big, Anglo-Saxon countries borrowing
massively from financial markets.
They're happy to do it at the moment, borrowing
very cheaply, two percent rio, you know, it's
not a big deal.
But the worry is that sometime, down the track,
markets will look at the U.K. and say, "Well,
is this a viable model?”
You know, you can't just keep borrowing like
this.
Debt piles up. Debt service grows.
There is then an adjustment. Their interest
rates go up.
That, in turn, pushes up your debt servicing.
It then becomes very, very serious.
And that's why the political debate has now
switched on to this whole issue of cuts, or
taxes -- do it two ways.
But the significance of it -- from what I'm
saying -- is that nobody believes now that
the government can continue to drive the economy
through spending and investment. It can't.
It's going to have a negative effect.
So the question then is, Where is this growth
going to come from?
And I've been down the list.
And apart from exports, it's difficult to
see.
So, the outcome of that analysis would be,
"Yeah, you know, recovery?
Sure.”
Plenty of signs of returning confidence, but
fairly anemic.
I don't want to get into the forecasting arguments
about whether it's 'double-dip recessions'
or 'flattening out' and so on.
But, I mean, you get the trend of my argument.
So that's all I really want to say about where
we are and where we're going from here.
I just want to finish up with flagging up
some of the big, difficult, long-term issues
that we've got to try and face coming out
of this crisis.
The first one, I've sort of half touched on
already, which is what kind of economic structure
this country's going to have five, ten years,
20 years down the track.
I mean, How is the British economy going to
change?
It's very clear that we became over-dependent
on financial services -- not that all financial
services are a bad thing. Clearly, they're
not.
And many of the things that are happening
in the City are very useful.
But we became over-dependent on a source of
revenue growth -- employment tax revenue -- that
was just too unstable.
And then, we were almost in the position of
Iceland -- not quite as extreme, but over-dependent
on the banking sector.
So, relatively speaking, that's going to have
to contract.
So what's going to grow in its place?
Well, new forms of trade-able activities and
manufacturing -- not necessarily metal-bashing,
but industry in the widest sense, including
creative industries.
That's the space that's going to have to be
occupied.
That raises questions about whether, as a
country, we've got the skills, the education,
to make it happen.
That's where we have to start looking.
Second big question is, What do you do about
this very big, financial sector that's fouled
up seriously -- caused a lot of damage?
And here, I think -- although the government
was broadly right last October -- they have
completely taken their eyes off the ball.
Haven't focused, for example, on how you make
sure that the banks that have been rescued
-- make sure that capital gets out to solvent
companies.
A lot of companies are still going by the
ball, because the banks have stopped lending.
They've lurched from, you know, ludicrously
excessive lending to ultra-conservative lending.
The government, in my view, should have stepped
in and smoothed it out.
But they have a complicated problem because
of the role of regulation.
But it's not worked.
But looking beyond that, How do we make sure
that the big banks are structured in such
a way that they don't destabilize the British
economy anymore?
And let's not forget, Britain is the center
for the world's big banks.
Three out of the five biggest banks of the
world, in balance sheet terms, were British
in the run-up to this crisis.
RBS -- which is the biggest bank in the world
-- went down.
Barclay's just survived.
HSBC floated away reasonably comfortably,
having been very well-managed.
Lloyds, another very big bank, has gone down
-- dragged down by H Boss.
So we've had a very, very big banking sector
-- exceptionally large banking sector -- and
the question is how you restructure.
Lots of technical arguments here.
But my very simple view is that we can not
continue to have the situation where you have
very, very large banks, which take big risks
in their international activity, which then,
when they overreach themselves, have to be
underwritten by the British taxpayer.
We can't allow this situation to happen again.
And that means, probably, we're going to have
to have a dual system where you have, on the
one hand, competitive banks -- that don't
depend on taxpayer support -- go out and do
their own thing, hedge funds or whatever -- take
risks -- commercial, business-minded, purely
private sector.
They can stand or fail by their own competitive
performance.
And then, on the other hand, you have utilities,
which are run and regulated like water companies,
which don't take risks, -- except on a kind
of microlevel with small business -- are run
very safely, provide credit to normal business
customers, take your deposits, and operate
in a very traditional, conservative way.
I think that has to be the clear separation
at some point in the next few years.
So that's the second question.
How do you sort out the financial sector?
I don't think the government's even begun,
really, to get to grips with that.
And the third and the final point I want to
make and I'll finish on this now.
I think the one major thing that's affected
the world in all this is that, it's changed
the center of gravity of the world economy
in a quite radical way.
Until this crisis, it became part of the conventional
wisdom that China and India were becoming
major powers.
Their GNP, measured in purchasing power terms,
put them right up at the top.
China -- before the crisis -- was the second
biggest economy in the world.
India probably the fourth, if you measure
it properly.
You know, we all taught about this.
But I don't think -- until this crisis happened
-- we've quite realized how important these
countries are economically.
I remember, only a few years ago, the Governor
of Hong Kong, Chris Patten, coming back and
saying on television, "Don't get so excited
about China.
It's only got an economy the size of Belgium.”
You begin to realize it's taken an awful long
time to call on board what's happening in
the real world.
You know, these are very big countries with
very big economies that make a big difference.
And when they move, they move big, and they
suck in vast amounts of oil and commodities.
China was pumping out vast quantities of cheap
manufacturers.
That was what was giving us the illusion of
low inflation.
It wasn't really low inflation, because the
inflation was in the property market.
So these countries have been making waves
for a very long time -- or at least certainly
for the last two decades.
And what's happened now is that, whereas the
Western economies have stalled and stalled
very badly -- and will probably lag behind
now for several years till we get out of this
mess -- the Chinese and Indian economies are
storming ahead.
What's happened in China is extraordinarily.
They've applied classic Keynesian methods.
They were worried about a recession.
They have pumped vast amounts of money into
infrastructure, trying to get their consumers
spending.
You know, things could go wrong there.
They could have problems -- political problems.
But, as it looks at present, they're going
to grow very rapidly.
And the gap between China and the States is
going to close much more quickly than we have
thought possible -- and between India, and
the other developed countries, is going to
close.
So the whole center of gravity is changing.
Therefore, the decision-making about the world
economy is changing.
And these guys, quite rightly, insisting that
they want to be at the top table deciding
the way the world is run.
And the significance of the meeting last week
is, de facto, they're there.
And they're now calling the shots.
And that's the big strategic change that's
happened and which this crisis has really,
really reinforced.
So thank you. Any questions? That's all I
want to say.
>> [Clapping]
Q Hi. I just wanted to know what you thought
the role of the FSA was?
Vince Cable: The role of the FSA?
Q Whether it was to blame at all?
Vince Cable: Yeah. Well, they made a terrible
mess of supervising the banks, you know.
And they have more or less put their hands
up and acknowledged that.
I think there is sort of a bit of a myth that
there wasn't any regulation of the banks.
There was. There was some quite extensive
regulation.
There were regulators crawling over the banks,
but they didn't supervise them.
Slightly different -- regulation, supervision
-- not quite the same.
The supervision of the banks was negligent.
And we had the problem with Northern Rock
-- which they didn't see coming, although
there were plenty of warnings about it.
There were plenty of warnings about H Boss,
and they disregarded it.
So they made a complete hash of that.
But I think it's fair to say that the FSA,
under Lord Turner, has acknowledged their
weaknesses, is now recruiting better staff,
reorienting them, learning from the past.
One of my main quarrels with Mr. Rosenbaum's
approach to this is, I think that now that
they've learned their lessons, the worst possible
thing to do is to embark on a big, bureaucratic
restructuring.
You don't need to put the FSA in with the
Bank of England.
The Governor of the Bank of England needs
to have overall oversight of everything to
do with risk in the system -- systemic risk.
But the bread-and-butter operations of regulating
building societies and insurance companies
is an FSA matter and should be left alone.
And if what happens is what Mr. Osborne is
saying, as I understand it, the teams of people
-- who are now working on, for example, regulating
the insurance industry -- will be split in
two.
And there will be one lot that will go off
and look at systemic risk.
And another lot will go off and look at consumer
protection.
And there will be a lot of uncertainty and
a lot of people watching their backs.
And precisely, at this time, when we've really
got to get on top of the financial system
and start looking at it properly, we're going
to have a hiatus of a year, 18 months, whatever
-- everybody decides who is doing what job.
It's not helpful.
Q You talk about sort of splitting financial
industry into two -- into sort of a utility
part and a part that's able to do -- takes
bigger risks, has hedge funds, and so on.
Isn't there a risk that all the customers
are going to go to the hedge fund half of
the industry, and then, when it collapses
next time, it needs to be bailed out, because
everyone's borrowed money from it, and so
on?
Vince Cable: There is a risk, and what I'm
suggesting is not the perfect answer.
The point will be made against what I said
that some of the problems in the banking system
were not caused by the high-rollers in the
so-called 'casinos', but they were caused
by ordinary mortgage lending in Northern Rock
that was completely berserk, by fairly mundane
commercial property lending by H Boss in Scotland.
That's what really derailed H Boss.
So some people would argue -- and I don't
think this is your point -- that you can't
just artificially separate banking into the
high-risk bit and the low-risk bit.
It's not quite as simple as that.
And there is certainly a danger -- of the
point that you make -- that all these regulated,
but free enterprise, hedge funds could also
go belly up, and somebody might need to do
something about it.
I don't think there's a perfect answer to
that.
But the issue was raised ten years ago by
a man called Cruickshank, who produced a very
perceptive report about British banking.
And he said, "Look, the problem here."
And he warned -- I mean, it was the first
real warning that was given that, "There's
a real problem here.
The British banks are making returns on capital
that are far in excess of what you'd expect
in a low-risk industry.
Something odd about this.
And it's odd, because these are companies
that are all underwritten by the taxpayer.
So something has to happen.
Either they're set free of the taxpayer and
forced to compete -- go down.
Or we just accept that the banking industry
is an, essentially, state industry.
And it's got to be run by -- and for -- the
taxpayer, one or two levels removed.”
And he posed that problem.
The government clearly found that too difficult
to handle.
They didn't want a confrontation with the
bankers.
They let it go.
It may be that you're right and that my approach
of just splitting the thing down the middle
doesn't work.
But if it doesn't work, then actually, what
we would have to argue for is much, much tighter
regulation of the whole lot.
But I'm trying to get a middle way.
Q I really got two questions.
For this two-system approach to work, wouldn't
we need global agreement for it to happen?
And I guess, to use your analogy of the patient,
Isn't it inevitable -- as we develop better,
more sophisticated drugs -- the patient is
going to push themselves harder, so eventually,
to the point of breaking?
Isn't that just human nature?
Especially, brute human nature?
Vince Cable: Well, yes. I mean, that's a rather
fatalistic conclusion.
And, you know, and there are people who are
arguing that.
They say, "Well, what's the point of bringing
in more regulation, because the guys will
find a way around it?
They're clever and driven by greed, or whatever.
And you can't stop it. That's the way people
are.
So what's the point, you know? Let it all
happen again.”
You know? And I just think that's the counsel
of despair, actually.
We do have to try to make the system better,
while understanding there will be people out
there who are constantly trying to find a
way of breaking through -- breaking the rules.
I mean, you have this in your own industry,
right?
You're an innovative industry, moving very
fast.
You've got regulators who are trying to catch
up with you.
And it's very much the same in banking.
The problem is, I don't think you can destroy
the world economy -- maybe you can -- but
in the way that the bankers have been able
to, or almost.
So we have to try -- though you're absolutely
right that, particularly in a free enterprise
system, there are limits to what regulation
can do to restrain seriously damaging behavior.
Q So you said we were 24 hours away from the
banking system going into complete global
meltdown.
Vince Cable: That's how it looked in the U.K.
yeah.
Q So, I just wondered, What could have actually
happened and how bad things could have actually
gone? What 'meltdown' actually means?
Vince Cable: Well, I don't want to be too
flesh-creeping.
I mean, I think the way the government or
the bank described it, you know, that kind
of the ATM system would probably just have
stopped working for awhile.
You know, banks would have just ceased to
function for awhile.
But, in that kind of environment, governments
just step in and do it.
The idea that we would have returned to some
kind of Stone Age -- it would never have happened.
But if it would have been allowed to continue,
it would have been really horrific.
And of course, other banks would have collapsed
-- not just IBS.
You know.
Some of the others that were near the edge
would have gone over too.
>> [pause]
Q Where there's very low interest rates and
the government's pumped a lot of money into
the system, what's your view on the risk that
this will create another bout of serious inflation
and a second very-serious debt?
Vince Cable: The question -- I don't know
whether it was heard at the back -- was about
whether there is a danger of return to inflation.
I think the professional assessment at the
moment is that the risks of that happening
are very low.
That there is a greater risk, at the moment,
of lurching back into deflation; in other
words, falling prices.
The one scenario that has horrified the central
bankers and governments too is that we do
get into a world of falling prices, falling
output, falling wages.
You know, we've seen that in past episodes
in history.
We have been on the edge of that.
I think it's actually true at the moment that
prices are falling.
I haven't seen the latest indicators.
It depends which measure you use.
And that is a very dangerous world, because
if prices start to fall seriously and systemically,
then the real value of people's debt and company's
debt, of course, grows.
And that increases the extent to which you
are trapped in a 'debt deflation', as it's
called.
And governments and central banks have been
desperate to make sure that doesn't happen.
There is a risk of overreacting.
There is a risk of that happening.
There's very little sign of it happening.
And I think, the central banks -- including
our own Bank of England -- are acutely conscious
that, you know, this is a latent problem.
And, if it started to become apparent, they
would react quickly with interest rate increases.
So I think the sequence of events has been
properly thought through.
There is a bigger danger in the longer run
than the one you described.
It isn't that there's an accidental spillover
into inflation, but that governments take
the view that they've got such problems managing
public debt that it would be easier to let
inflation rip to wipe it out.
This is what's happened in the past.
The British government debt after the Second
World War in relation to our economy was far,
far bigger than it is today. Far bigger.
It was after the First World War.
It was in much of the 19th century.
And these things were dealt with through inflation.
Governments let inflation wipe out past debt.
And I think some people worry that this is
a big temptation in future.
The one restraint on that temptation is that
the Bank of England is now independent.
It has an inflation target.
And I can't see any government publicly saying
to the Bank of England, "We want you guys
to run higher inflation.”
Don't see it. Politically, it couldn't happen,
I don't think.
Q With Mr. Osborne's star waning and broad,
cross-party support and respect for your insight,
do you think there's a good chance that you
accept the offer to be the inevitable, next,
Conservative Parliament's chancellor?
Vince Cable: No. No.
>> [Laughter]
Vince Cable: The system doesn't work like
that.
It's not like football, you know, where you
have an agent and you go off from Man U to
Man City. It's not like that.
I mean, we have parties.
We work as parties. We are loyal to our teams,
actually.
I mean, there is real loyalty and commitment.
And we're elected as Lib Dems or Conservatives.
And we stick with our people -- unless you
have a civil war as happened in the later
party in the early 80's.
But, you know, we stick with our people.
So it's not a question of my going off and
doing something.
It's a question about what the combination
of parties is after the next election and
what comes out of that.
But that's not for us to decide. The public
decides that.
>> [pause]
Q Can you guys hear? Okay.
So I have a few friends who are working for
the brokerage places.
And whenever I chat with them, they're, "Yeah.
It's pretty much back to business as usual.”
They're doing the expensive lunches and having
a lot of fun.
Is it possible that the country tries to ignore
this and kind of reset to the way it was?
Like, could that even happen?
Or, has so much damage been done that it's
actually impossible?
Vince Cable: I didn't quite hear all of it.
But were you just saying there's a potential
danger of return to the same behavior that
caused the problem?
Was that the question? Yeah.
I think there is, you know.
And I meet an awful lot of people in the financial
community.
And it's a year ago, but you know, a year
ago is a century ago.
But life's getting back to normal, and Why
shouldn't they get back to normal?
And, you know, there were people who warned
-- philosophically and practically -- about
the dangers of a bank rescue.
That it's a so-called problem of "moral hazard.”
There was a 19th century philosopher called
Herbert Spencer who was a follower of Darwin.
And he produced, what I thought, was the most
pungent definition of 'moral hazard'.
He said, "If fools are allowed to profit from
their folly, we populate the world with fools."
And that, in a way, could happen in the financial
system.
People who've been rescued say, "Okay, fine.
That's good.
If we get into trouble again, we'll go rescue
it again.
Let's push things to the edge.”
And there is a real, real danger of that happening.
That's why the government has to be much more
aggressive, I think, on the bonus culture
and so on, than it has been.
Because it's so very easy to slide back into
bad habits, knowing that someone else is eventually
going to pick up the pieces for you.
Q What is going on in the U.K. domestic property?
Vince Cable: Sorry?
Q Sorry. What is going on at the moment in
the U.K. domestic property market?
Vince Cable: You're talking about commercial
or residential?
Q Residential.
Vince Cable: I don't know. It's a strange
phenomenon what's happening in residential
property.
There was a lot of analysis done before the
crash -- the I.M.F. and others -- who suggested
that, on any reasonable assessment of fundamentals
-- fundamentals being supply and demand and
the relationship of price to people's incomes,
because that's what determines what you can
borrow.
The British domestic property market was probably
30 percent overvalued. Probably.
And we know from previous episodes in history
that, when you get a market correction, it
goes more than that before it stabilizes.
So there is a question, "Why hasn't that happened?”
It has happened in a few parts of the country.
You've had a really big crash in some of the
East Midlands cities.
In the middle of Manchester -- middle of Leeds
-- where you've got these big blocks of flats
which, you know, the developers can't sell,
and that's driven down the price.
But it hasn't happened in London, except in
little pockets.
Now, there are two theories about it.
One is that it's just a matter of time that
this correction will happen.
That, at the moment, the market is being artificially
sustained by the fact that, you know, property
is being withheld, and there isn't the supply
and this is artificially creating stable prices
in the short run. That's one view.
The other view is that, you know, something
fundamental has changed.
You know, make up of families, migration,
have created supply and demand at a different
level.
And I'm not a forecaster, let alone a forecaster
in property markets.
My hunch is that it's the former rather than
the latter, but I'm certainly not in the business
of giving you financial advice as to when
to buy and sell houses.
Q To your point earlier about your Herbert
Spencer quote and also your first conclusion
about the new industries that are going to
have to take the place of the financial service
industry.
Do you think there is anything the government
can do to incentivize the new 'brightest and
best' from the next generation to not go into
financial services?
Because you can see already that they're still
being incentivized by the bonus culture, and
the top tier are being taken into those banks
still.
Is there anything the government can do to
drive them into the new industries that we
need?
Vince Cable: Well, I'm not sure the government
can directly do very much.
I mean, we don't have labor conscription,
and I wouldn't advocate it.
I think, to some extent, there is an element
of fashion.
You know, there was a whole generation who
felt that the really smart thing to do -- if
you got a good first, you know -- is to go
to work for Goldman Sachs or Lehman's.
It was the intellectual cream, and you can
make pots of money.
So, you know, but I think that wave has probably
gone.
I suspect those people probably now want to
come and work for you.
I don't know, but I suspect they might.
Probably what needs to happen -- I'm not sure
how you make this happen.
You can't force labor markets -- is that,
One of our big problems is that lots of kids,
you know, who've got real mathematical ability,
for example, would do physics, engineering.
You know, what's the incentive for them to
do it?
They're going into fairly low-paid jobs, relative
little upside.
And somehow or other, we need to change the
psychology so that that becomes a really attractive
thing for people to do.
I mean, as it happens, my youngest son -- who
I mentioned -- didn't succumb to the temptation
to go into the banks.
He realized his dad's own pea salary could
probably keep him going for a few years.
So did his Ph.D. in physics research and is
now doing theoretical physics.
But it's not very well-rewarded, and it's
a very insecure world, because universities
are being cut.
So somehow or other, we've got to try and
create an environment where the really trendy
thing to do is not to work for an investment
bank, but to become a physicist or an engineer
or a chemist, or the kind of things you do.
But, you're in a position to give incentives.
>> [pause]
Q What would you say to the argument that,
"A lot of the problems we're experiencing
now stem from a decision that the U.S. government
made all those years ago to, basically, de-link
its currency from the gold standard.”
And would you say a reversal of this decision
is perhaps a panacea for the problems that
we're experiencing now?
Vince Cable: No. I don't think so.
I mean, that's a bygone world.
You know, we've lifted exchange controls;
capital can move around.
It isn't easy to sustain currency pegs any
longer.
You know, the traumas in 1992, Black Monday.
Once a country tries to hold an exchange rate
against speculative trends, it's bound to
lose, but it's a one-way bet.
So I think we have to accept that the major
currency areas, which will be the U.S. dollar
area, the Chinese area -- whatever we now
call that -- the Euro area.
You know, these are going to float against
each other.
And it's not possible to fix them, in practice.
I think what your question does touch on is
that, one of the underlying sources of instability
is the big imbalances between what happened
in the United States and China -- the very
odd situation really -- where you had essentially
a poor country saving more than it could invest
at home, exporting it, exporting their savings
to a rich country that was living beyond its
means.
And I'm not trying to make moral judgments.
It's just a fact of life.
And vast quantities of Chinese savings flowed
into the United States and helped to finance
its government and private deficits.
And that worked great for awhile; you know,
it kept the world economy growing over the
last decade or so.
But it was doomed to come to an end, and it
is in the process of coming to an end because
of the crisis that's being caused by the flood
of Chinese liquidity into western economies.
And if you read behind what's being said at
the G-20 meeting, a lot of the debate is about
how you achieve that rebalancing in an orderly
way.
How do you make sure that Chinese savings
goes into Chinese development?
And that's linked to the issue of their exchange
rate.
How does the United States adjust to be a
better-balanced economy?
But I think simply going back, we can't really
talk about going back to the pre-1971 world.
That doesn't exist anymore.
>> [pause]
Q You mentioned previously that you essentially
agreed with the rescue package that the government
put forward to get us out of this crisis.
And I saw yesterday that Alistair Darling
is now talking about bringing in a law or
regulation to limit the amount of debt in
one year the government can go up to.
Is that not, in some way, tying the hands
of the government in the future?
Vince Cable: No, I don't think that's sensible.
Let me clear what I said.
I think -- in the emergency last autumn -- I
think the government did the right thing,
in terms of recapitalizing banks, providing
the guarantees, being willing to step in,
semi-nationalize, the drastic cuts in interest
rates by the Bank of England.
I mean, all those -- that package was the
right thing to do in an emergency.
And it prevented a very bad situation getting
even worse.
I think, since then, they've let a lot of
things drift.
And one of the things that's been allowed
to drift is the lack of attention to the flow
of credit into the business sector -- keeping
business going.
I think they've not paid enough attention
to that.
And, arguably, not addressing sufficiently
up front the looming issue of the public sector
deficit.
So I'm not criticizing the fact that we have
a large deficit, because conditions have arisen
that made it inevitable.
But there has to be a very clear plan to get
rid of it.
Now, the particular proposal that came up
yesterday, "Let's have a legal target.”
Well, what does that mean, you know?
If Alistair Darling misses it, does he go
to prison?
You know, it's a political process.
It's not a legal problem.
And you know, he wants to go down the legal
route.
George Osborne wants to set up a quango to
deal with this.
You can't deal with this in that way.
It's got to be dealt with up front.
We've got a big deficit.
The politicians have got to spell out very
clearly what this means in terms of public
spending choices and taxation.
It is a purely political matter and we've
got to level with you about what the options
are, and then, you're going to vote on it.
But hiding behind new laws and quangos does
not deal with the problem.
>> [pause]
Q I actually did a physics degree at university.
And two years ago, I made the choice between
doing a Ph.D. or coming here.
And I sold out to come here -- well, a company
that was bought by here.
And I wondered what you think we can actually
do to stop people like me taking these jobs,
and actually.
Vince Cable: Well, I don't want to make you
feel guilty.
I don't know what you do.
Q I definitely remembered saying, "I'm selling
out.”
And I did sell out.
And so, I guess my point is, I know there's
been efforts made in the past.
I know there's less and less people doing
physics and maths.
There's departments closing around the country.
What can we really do to stop this?
Vince Cable: I think that -- as far as the
deterioration in British science and mathematics
is concerned -- I think the penny has dropped.
I had a debate in parliament four years ago
that I picked up -- I was personally interested
in it, because my constituency houses the
National Physical Laboratory and the Laboratory
of the Government Chemists.
You know, I have lots of physicists and chemists
who are living in my area.
And I think the government realized four years
ago -- three, four years ago -- there's a
really big, emerging crisis.
Because very large numbers of kids are coming
through the system without basic mathematical
literacy.
Not enough further maths.
Most of the further maths and physics is taught
in private schools.
You know, the state system is just not delivering.
And I think they have now focused on that,
in terms of helping recruit more properly-qualified
teachers who can do specialism, not generalities.
And it's beginning to make a difference.
But it's a slow -- it's like turning around
an oil tanker.
You know, it doesn't happen overnight.
Q [inaudible]
Vince Cable: Well, it is hard, you know. Making
brains work is hard.
>> Okay. I think we'll have to leave it there.
Thank you very much, Dr. Vince Cable.
Vince Cable: Thank you.
>> [Applause]